[موسيقى]
مجموعات مستوطنين تقتحم المسجد الاقصى
ومصلون فلسطينيون يعتصمون في باحاته
الجيش تايوان يرصد بوارج ومقاتلات صينيه
وبكين تواصل مناورات تطويق الجزيره
مسؤول ايراني يؤكد قدره بلاده على تقسيم
اليورانيوم باي نسبه مطلوبه وفي اي وقت
[موسيقى]
لو نشرى من القدس حيث افادت مصادر العربيه
باقتحام سته مجموعات من المستوطنين تضم
276 او 276 مستوطنا باحث الاقصى صباح
اليوم وجاءت هذه الاقتحامات على عده
مجموعات تحت حراسه مشدده من الشرطه وادى
المستوطنون طقوسا تلموديا هذا وكشفت وكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه عن قيام الجيش
الاسرائيلي بتحويل باحات المسجد الاقصى
الى دكنه عسكريه لتامين اقتحامات
المستوطنين لساحات الحرم في اليوم الرابع
من عيد الفصح اليهودي حيث نصبت القوات
الاسرائيليه الحواجز داخل اسوار البلده
القديمه وافرغت شوارعها من الشبان تمهيدا
لاقتحام المستوطنين
من القدس مباشره تلتحق بنا مراسله العربيه
لانك الغاسله لان مرحبا بك معي في هذه
النشا صباح الخير اولا ماذا لديك من
معلومات حول هذه الاقتحامات المستوطنين
لباحات المسجد الاقصى كذلك ايضا ان كانت
هناك معلومات عن ما نتج عنها
المسجد الاقصى المبارك منذ الصباح اليوم
هناك اقتحامات كبيره باعداد مرتفعه من قبل
المستوطنين بحمايه مشدده من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن ارتفاع اعداد
المقتحمين من 200 الى 500 مستوطن قاموا
باقتحامه منذ ساعات الصباح على شكل
مجموعات متفرقه بحمايه كبيره من القوات
الاسرائيليه وانتشار مكثف ايضا في للقوات
الاسرائيليه في البلده القديمه وحاراتها
وايضا على ابواب المسجد وفي القدس بشكل
عام ايضا كان هناك اغلاق على الضفه
الغربيه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مدد
الاغلاقات للحواجز الاسرائيليه بين الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه وايضا كان هناك اغلاق
على قطاع غزه ايضا منع اعداد كبيره من
الفلسطينيين من الخروج او حتى منع بشكل
كامل خروج الفلسطينيين من قط غزه الى
اسرائيل سواء للصلاه سواء للعمل لجميع
الاسباب وذلك بسبب التوترات الامنيه كان
من المقرر اليوم ان يعود الاوضاع الى
طبيعتها وفتح الحواجز ولكن وزير الدفاع
بسبب التوترات الامنيه قام وقرر بانه سوف
يقوم بتمديد هذه الاغلاقات حتى نهايه
الاعياد اليهوديه وبالتالي هل نتجه عن هذه
الاغلاقات عن حمايه القوات الاسرائيليه
للمستوطنين نتج عنها مواجهات بين
المستوطنين والشرطه الاسرائيليه مع
المعتصمين الفلسطينيين
اكثر بشكل كبير على اعداد المعتكفين في
المسجد الاقصى لان في الجمعه الاولى
والثانيه كان هناك تسهيلات من قبل يعني
تسميها اسرائيل تسهيلات وهي السماح بدخول
اعداد من الفلسطينيين للصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى ولكن هذه الجمعه الثالثه كان هناك
الاغلاق وادى الى انخفاض كبير في اعداد
الفلسطينيين في الجمعه الثانيه شاهدنا
هناك ربع مليون فلسطيني ومصلي قاموا باداء
صلاه الجمعه في المسجد الاقصى ولكن في
الجمعه الثالثه كان هناك انخفاض كبير وصل
اعداد المصلين الى 130 الف مصلين فقط هذا
ايضا يؤثر على اعداد المعتكفين المتواجدين
في المسجد الاقصى الذين في العاده
يتواجدون في المسجد القبلي وساحات الاقصى
يعني للتصدي لاقتحامات القوات القوات
الاسرائيليه وايضا المستوطنين في طبيعه
الحال القوات الاسرائي تقوم بتفريغ
الساحات المسجد الاقصى والمسجد القبلي
ليلا حتى تتمكن من تامين اقتحام
المستوطنين في صباح اليوم التالي ولكن
ليله امس كان هناك اعداد كبيره من
المعتكفين لذلك القوات الاسرائيليه لم
تستطع اقتحام المسجد القبلي ولكن كان هناك
تواجد مكثف للقوات الاسرائيليه سواء على
الابواب او حتى في الساحات المسجد الاقصى
الاوضاع الان ايضا كذلك في البلده القديمه
لنا يعني هل يمكن ايجاز الوضع هناك
الحواجز ايضا التي وضعتها الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في البلده القديمه كيف تبدو
حتى هذه اللحظه وهلا زالت هذه الحواجز
موجوده الى الان
الصوره هي متوتره بل متوتره جدا بظل هذه
الاقتحامات هناك اعداد من المصلين
والمعتكفين داخل المسجد الاقصى يهتفون
الله اكبر ويهتفون اهتافات ضد المستوطنين
واقتحاماتهم للمسجد الاقصى ولكن يعني كان
هناك ايضا توتر كبير فجر اليوم حيث منعت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه اعداد من الشبان من
دخول المسجد واداء صلاه الفجر داخله لذلك
عدد من الشبان قاموا باداء الصلاه داخل
اسوار المسجد الاقصى وايضا نتحدث عن
انتشار مكثف للقوات الاسرائيليه بالنسبه
للحواجز هي ما زالت موجوده هناك تفتيش
لبعض المصلين الذين يدخلون من الابواب
المسجد الاقصى الى ساحاته اشكرك يا جزيلا
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات والاضاحات من
القدس انضمت الينا مراسله العربيه اللانك
الخاصيه
على الجبهات السوريه فهدى بيان لوزاره
دفاع نظام السوري بان الدفاعات الجويه
تصدت لهجوم اسرائيلي بالصواريخ جنوب
البلاد واعترضت بعضها اسرائيل كانت اعلنت
قصفا مجمع لجيش النظام السوري وانظمه
رادار عسكريه ومواقع مدفعيه تستخدمها
قواته دون تحديد مكان المواقع المستهدفه
قبل ذلك قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف
بواسطه طائره مسيره منصات لاطلاق صواريخ
من سوريا وذلك ردا على ثلاث عمليات لاطلاق
الصواريخ من سوريا باتجاه الجولان المحتل
اوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي ان منظومه القبه
الحديديه تمكنت من اعتراض صواريخ بما سقط
او صاروخ فيما سقط صاروخان في مناطق
مفتوحه من جنوب الجولان كما قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالمدفعيه موقعا في درعا
السوريه بعد اطلاق الصواريخ فيما تبنى
فصيل يدعى لواء القدس في سوريا تبنى اطلاق
الصواريخ اذكروا ان هذا الفصيل
الفلسطيني هو فصيل مسلح موالي للنظام
السوري
هذا ونشر الجيش الاسرائيلي صورا للغاره
التي استهدفت قاذفه صواريخ في سوريا بعد
اطلاق عده صواريخ وسقوطها في مرتفعات
الجولان
بدوره قال مصدر عسكري والمسؤول في الجيش
الاردني ان صاروخا انفجر في الهواء في
منطقه وادي عقربه المحاديه للحدود السوريه
ما ادى الى سقوط شظايا في نفس المنطقه
وكذا المصدر عدم وقوع اضرار بالارواح او
الممتلكات مشيرا الى ان الفرق المختصه من
سلاح الهندسه الملكي ستتعامل مع موقع
الحادث للكشف عن اي تفاصيل اخرى
ينضم الينا من كوفنتري مدير المرصده
السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن سيد
رامي مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره ما
المتوفر لديك من معلومات حول هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي على سوريا هل استهدف فقط منصات
اطلاق الصواريخ التي
يعني اتجهت الى الجولان المحتل وسقطت هناك
طبعا صباح الخير
لا يوجد اي تواجد بما يعرف بنواء القدس
الذي نتحدث عنه يقوده محمد سعيد في منطقه
الجولان المحتله او القنيطره هناك من اطلق
الصواريخ ما تعرف بالمقاومه السوريه تحرير
الجولان وقد يكون مسمى لواء القدس ولكن لا
علاقه له بنظام القدس العامل ضمن الفرق
الخبز بالنسبه للطائرات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت اللواء 90 في منطقه القنيطره قرب
الجولان السوري
وايضا استهدفت اللواء 52 في ريف درعا
الشرقي واستهدفت كتيبه للرادارات في ريف
السويداء الغربي بالاضافه للقصف المدفعي
الذي اول الدبابات الذي استهدف مناطق عند
يعني في عند الحدود مع الجولان المحتال
سواء يريد درع الغربي او ريف القنيطره
المتداخل مع ريف درعا الغربي اي ان
الاستهداف طاله المدفعي او الدبابات طالب
محيط الجولان المحتل وايضا القصف الجوي
طال اللواء 90 وطالع ريف درع الشرقي وريف
السويداء الغربي في ريف الشرقي وريف السوي
هناك كتائب للرادارات كي لا تشوش على
الطائرات الاسرائيليه بينما اللواء
التفعيل هو مسؤول عن محافظه القنيطره وقد
يكون مسؤول بصوره او باخرى عن اطلاق
الصواريخ السوريه او الصواريخ التي اطلقت
باتجاه المعتل طيب انت قلت ان القدس لم
يكن هو من يعني نفذ هذه العمليه عمليه
اطلاق الصواريخ من الاراضي السوريه باتجاه
الجولان المحتل
اذا من قام بهذه العمليه ما هو هذا الفصيل
ايضا الذي قام بهذه العمليه
ما تعرف بالمقاومه السوريه بتحرير الجولان
بشقه الفلسطيني التابع لاحد الحركات
الفلسطينيه الموجوده في سوريا او يشقها
السوري المجرد من قبل حزب الله اللبناني
والحرس الثوري الايراني بتسهيلات من
المخابرات العسكريه وتسهيلات بقوات النظام
للتحرك بحريه في تلك المنطقه هذا ما جرى
عليه بين قصف الصواريخ سواء قبل منتصف
الليل وبعض منتصف الليل وبالتالي ليس هو
لواء القدس الفلسطيني المدعوم من من روسيا
هو من نفذ هذه العمليه هذا ما تاكده طيب
ممتاز الهدف من هذا القصف الاسرائيلي هل
كان فقط الرد على هذه العمليه على منصه
اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه الجولان المحتل ام
ان هناك اهداف اخرى ايضا لهذا القصف كما
تعودنا بشكل يعني اصبح روتيني خلال الايام
الماضيه باستهداف بعض المواقع في الاراضي
السوريه لربما ميليشيات ايرانيه ايضا او
غيرها لا هو الهدف يعني الهدف هو كان
الرادارات بكلمهوش على الطائرات
الاسرائيليه
المسؤول عن منطقه القنيطره لا يوجد اي
مستودعات قصفت الله اللبناني الالحاد
الثوره الايراني او حتى اي تجمعات لهذه
الميليشيات او التابعه لايران او لحزب
الله لكن الواقع هذه المره كان الهدف على
نقاط عسكريه تابعه بين المزدوج
ين يتواجد حزب الله في اللواء 90 او في
مناطق طبعا اللواء 90 ولكن الواقع بان
النقاط التي قصفت هي تعرف من قبل السوريين
بان الجيش العربي السوري او للقوات النظام
سميها ماشيه لكن دعنا نقول بان حزب الله
موجود في المنطقه حزب الله موجود في
القنيطره موجود في درعا تحت مسميات مختلفه
موجود في اضيف دمشق الجنوبي الغربي وهو
يمكن يعني ربما ما يفسر التساؤل عن عن
القذف الذي طال ايضا كذلك درعا بان هذه
المنطقه تتواجد فيها فلول لحزب الله
الشيخ القطع حزب الله موجود في كامل
الجنوب السوري تحت بلباس مختلف تحت
المسميات مختلفه ليس فقط تحتها يعني موجود
تحت حزب الله حزب الله قلت له عناصر في
القصف الاسرائيلي الاراضي السوريه فقد
خلال الايام الفائته ثلاثه عناصر من حزب
الله قتلوا سواء في حمص او في دمشق شكرا
جزيلا لك من كوفنتريم مدير السوري لحقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
تؤكد ان الجاره الشماليه اوقفت الاتصالات
عبر الخط العسكري الساخن لليوم الثالث
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اكد الجيش الصيني
لاستمرار في مناورات تطويق جزيره تايوان
والمياه المحيطه بها وقال الجيش الصيني في
بيان انه نفذ محاكاه لتوجيه ضربات دقيقه
على اهداف رئيسيه داخل تايوان ومحيطها عبر
عشرات المقاتلات الجويه والقوات البريه
واشار الجيش ايضا الى زياده زخم المناورات
من جهه اعلن الجيش والتايواني رصد 9 سفن
حربيه و58 مقاتله جويه صينيه حول الجزيره
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤولون في كوريا الجنوبيه ان الجاره
الشماليه اوقفت الاتصالات عبر الخط
العسكري الساخن لليوم الثالث على التوالي
لاسباب غير واضحه ذكرت وكاله انباء يونيها
بالكوريا الجنوبيه ان العاده تقضي بان
تجري الكوريتان مكالمتين يوميا عبر الخطوط
الساخنه العسكريه وخطوط الاتصال عبر
الحدود لكن كوريا الشماليه توقفت عن الرد
على المكالمات الوارده من الجنوب منذ
الجمعه
قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي ان الطيران لديها القدره على
تخصيب اليورانيوم متى شاءت وباي نسبه كانت
واضاف اسلامي في مقابله مع التلفزيون
الايراني ان هدف الولايات المتحده كان
ايقاف التكنولوجيا النوويه الايرانيه
لكنها فشلت في ذلك ولم تحقق اي نتائج بحسب
تعبيره
كشف معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي ان القوات
الروسيه ستلجا الى استخدام المدفعيه
لتعويض تدهور القدرات الهجوميه بسبب نقص
الرصاص على جبهه القتال واستند المعهد
الامريكي لتصريح القائد المدعومي من
الكرملين
الذي اشار فيه لان القياده الروسيه تعطي
الاولويه لامدادات ذخيره مدفعيه بشكل صارم
بسبب النقص
من جهتها قلت القياده الجنوبيه للجيش
الاوكراني ان الاسطول البحريه الروسي في
البحر الاسود يحتفظ بحاملتي صواريخ تحمل
قذائف من طراز كليبر بالاضافه الى غواصتين
من الصعب كشفهما عبر وسائل الدفاع الجوي
واشارت الى ان اعلان التاهب بسبب خطر
اطلاق صواريخ من البحر الاسود يعني انه من
الضروري على السكان التحرك والمغادره
باسرع ما يمكن
نهر دجله اليوم يختلف كثيرا عن الامس فهو
يعاني من ارتفاع في نسب التلوث تجعله غير
صالح للاستخدام البشري او الزراعي عدد
كبير من العراقيين عبروا عن استيائهم من
مدى تلوث مياه نهر دجله وتاثيره السلبي
على الصيد والبيئه
يعني شو اقول لك ريحه وساخه يعني هي هي
العالم هي سبب التلوث كليتها زين يعني يجي
هنا يقعد يذبلك مدري شنو وقزاز
زين المؤيد
تلوث وساخه
وقصب وهاي الشغلات
ومي مو نظيف واستمتع عندنا اطلع حتى بيها
نفط الصوره الاساسيه على صيد الاسماك يقلل
من تواجدها بالنهار وثاني شيء حتى طعمها
يختلف يعني
دجله الخير لم يعد كذلك فمياهه العذبه
اصبحت ملوثه بشكل شبه كامل تعددت الاسباب
والنتيجه واحده مياه غير صالحه للاستخدام
او الشرب
90% نسبه التلوث في نهر دجله هذا ما
اعلنته وزاره البيئه العراقيه رقم صادم
جعل موضوع التلوث على سلم اولويات الوزاره
لوضع خطط عاجله للحد من خطورته اشاره
البيئه باعتبارها وزاره اشرافيه تبذل جهود
جديه لالزام الجهات الملوثه باتخاذ
الاجراءات اللازمه للمحافظه على المصادر
المائيه من التلوث هنالك لجنه عليا
لمواجهه تاثير او مواجهه استمرار تلوث
المصادر المائيه يتراسها معالي وزير
البيئه وعضويه كل الجهات هذه اللجنه عملت
خارطه الطريق بخطط قصيره ومتوسطه وطويله
اثمرت بشكل جدي على تقليل احمر التلوث
للمصادر المائيه الدكتوره اقبال لطيف
المتخصصه بالتلوث البيئي تؤكد من خلال
ابحاثها ان نهري دجله والفرات ملوثان
بنسبه تامه ولا يصلحان للاستخدام البشري
كما هو الحال مع نهر ديالا وبحر النجف من
خلال توثيق للواقع البيئي في نهر دجله
ونهر الفرات ونهر دياله وبحر النجف وجدت
ان هناك تلوث عالي بنسبه 100% في نهر دجله
و100% في نهر الفرات وهذا التلوث هو لا
يصلح للاستهلاك البشري ولا الاستهلاك
الحيواني ولا يصح ايضا للراي خطورتها هذه
تكمن انه في حاله ارتفاع الصيف في
الارتفاع درجات الحراره
يحدث التبخر ويزيد من تركيز هذه العناصر
الثقيله
الملوثات الطبيه والصناعيه التي ترمى بشكل
مستمر من دون رادع في نهر دجله تجعل منه
بيئه خصبه لانتشار الامراض ما لم يتم
علاجها بشكل جدي خاصه في فصل الصيف روعه
بالنهر ممكن انه نلاحظ كميات ملوثه بالقرب
من مدينه الطب ممكن انه نلاحظ هناك كثير
من التلوث في المياه هذا يحتاج مثل ما
اسلفنا الى وحدات معالجه وحدات معالجه
حقيقيه وحديثه انه ليس تكون فقط هذه
الوحدات المعالجه تكون على الورق لكن يجب
ان تطبيق هذه المشاريع وفق خطط استراتيجيه
حديثه حتى تخدم البيئه العراقيه
مع هذه النسب المخيفه من التلوث لا يزال
العراقيون يعتبرون ان هذا النهر شريان
حياتهم
ومتنفسهم الوحيد سامر الكبيسي العربيه
بغداد
اعلن مسؤولون فرنسيون عن انهيار مبنى من
اربعه طوابق في مدينه مرسيليا الساحليه
جنوب فرنسا ما ادى الى اصابه خمسه اشخاص
على الاقل ولا تزال عمليات البحث عن
المزيد من الضحايا المحتملين قائمه واوضح
رئيس بلديه مرسيليا ان الانهيار كان نتيجه
انفجار لكن لم يتم تحديد اسبابه حتى الان
مؤكدا ان الحريق الهائله حال دون اقتحام
المبنى
في ختام هذه النشره تذكير بابرز عناوينها
مجموعات مستوطنين تقتحم المسجد الاقصى
ومصلون فلسطينيون يعتصمون في باحاته
جيش تايوان يرصد بوارج ومقاتلات صينيه
تواصل مناورات تطويق الجزيره
مسؤول ايراني يؤكد قدره بلاده على تخسيب
اليورانيوم باي نسبه مطلوبه وفي اي وقت
ساعه اخباريه مفصله على راس الساعه القاكم
فيها الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات